So right here we've listed two
quantities or two fluid volumes
right over here in terms
of gallons, 1 gallon and 2
gallons.
And what I want to
do in this video is
try to convert this quantity
of fluid, this volume of fluid,
I want to convert it into
these other units within the US
customary system.
So I encourage you
to pause the video
and first try to
do the 1 gallon.
Try to convert it into quarts,
pints, cups, and fluid ounces.
Well, 1 gallon is
equal to 4 quarts.
So we can just multiply by 4.
1 quart is equal to 2 pints,
so we can multiply this by 2.
So 4 quarts, each
of them are 2 pints.
4 times 2 gets us to 8 pints.
Each pint is equal to 2
cups, so we have 8 pints.
Each of them are
equal to 2 cups.
We're going to have 16 cups.
And then finally, if we're
converting from a cup
to a fluid ounce, each
cup is 8 fluid ounces.
So if we have 16 cups, it's
going to be 16 times 8.
8 times 8 is 64, and it's
going to be twice that.
That's going to be
128 fluid ounces.
Now, let's do the same
thing with 2 gallons.
Try to convert that into quarts,
pints, cups, and fluid ounces.
And I encourage you
to pause the video
and try it on your own first.
Well, same idea.
1 gallon is equivalent
to 4 quarts.
So 2 gallons are going to be
2 times 4 quarts, or 8 quarts.
quart is 2 pints.
So if we want to go
from quarts to pints,
we'd want to multiply by 2.
So this is going to be 16 pints.
And then each pint is 2 cups.
So multiplying 16 of them, then
that's going to be 32 cups.
And then finally,
each cup is 8 ounces.
32 times 8 is going to be?
Let's see, it's going to be 256.
And notice something here.
When we went from 1
gallon to 2 gallons,
we essentially increased the
quantity of gallons by 2,
or we multiplied by 2.
And you see that
across the board
here as it's going from
4 quarts to 8 quarts.
This is going from
8 pints to 16 pints.
16 cups to 32 cups,
going from 128
fluid ounces to 256.
When you increase the volume
in gallons by a factor of 2,
you're, of course, going
to increase the volume
in any unit you measure
it in by a factor of 2.